you called one of your opponents John
Jones you you really went after him you
trash talk to me yes I did you called
him crackhead yeah some people think
that you angered him too much because he
ended up winning the fight yes and you
don't even remember the end of the fight
no I know well I did but for some reason
people on Instagram feel like they
should remind me right so just tell
people what happened at the end of the
fight well I got knocked off
yeah and how I didn't want to watch it I
would watch the fight up until the point
that I got knocked out but then I was
like do I really want to watch the
ending well I didn't even have to make a
choice because the great fans of the
world decided to tag me on Instagram
time and time and time again so I was
like I don't remember this guys I would
have prefer to leave it that way but
thank you for ruining my days as I go
forward yeah you posted this picture of
you this was taken just before you I
think go out and and and do battle and
you say this is how you feel before
every fight is that true yes I sit there
and I think how many less did I take
when I should have went right to end up
at this arena where in about 3 hours I
have to fight somebody right and I'm
terrified and I'm nervous and then right
before the fight they put us on a marker
and they say DC you're walking in ten
and they give me a ten count and I'm
still like my heart's fluttering and I'm
terrified I'm scared
and then my music hits the speakers and
I run out to the Octagon and once I step
in there I because you know I fighting
the main event the vast majority of the
time and the UFC builds to the to the
end of the night and I can feel the
energy from the bottom of the Octagon
and I think to myself right before they
say fight there's no place in the world
I'd rather be fascinating you go from I
wish I could be anywhere else - this is
exactly where I want to be and I can
relate to that I think a lot of people
who have to go out and do something in
front of a lot of people yeah you have
to feel the fear in order to feel the
elation
I don't know why but I think that's
positive it's it's the only way to truly
appreciate what you get to do right
we're the lucky ones : we get to do what
we love and entertain people and and
compete and do these things that so many
people dream of
and I'm just I'm just real lucky be able
to do it yeah that's a great attitude
you're right we both were born with
incredible physical gifts and we're
using them to the best of our abilities
I'm gonna try it again Daniel's gonna be
fighting steep pay me Oh Cheech that's a
lot better : yeah gonna show your learn
I've had time to sober up for the
heavyweight title on UFC 2 to 6 on July
7th in Las Vegas tickets are still
available and the fight will be
available on pay-per-view you're gonna
break the curse of this chair yes you
were gonna dominate you were going to
win I'm gonna win this fight then I'll
bring two of these belts back I'll be
only the second guy in UFC history to
have two titles at the same time only
other one is your friend Conor McGregor
yeah so I'm gonna come back with both of
my belts and we'll sit on this chair and
then people will beg to come here yeah
rather than say no
[Applause]
you